Y cuando John y sus colegas
obtuvieron estas primeras muestras prístinas de aguas profundas preciosas,
los colocaron bajo el microscopio,
y vieron imágenes que se veían bastante así,
que en realidad las tomó en una expedición más reciente
mi estudiante de doctorado, Joy Buongiorno.
Puedes ver las cosas nebulosas en el fondo.
Eso es barro. Eso es barro del océano de aguas profundas,
y los puntos verdes brillantes teñidos con el tinte verde fluorescente
son microbios reales y vivos.
Debo decirles algo realmente trágico sobre los microbios.
Todos se ven iguales bajo un microscopio.
Quiero decir, en una primera aproximación.
Puedes tomar los organismos más fascinantes del mundo,
como un microbio que literalmente respira uranio,
y otro que hace combustible para cohetes,
mezclarlos con algo de barro del océano,
ponerlos bajo un microscopio,
y son solo pequeños puntos.
Es muy molesto.
No podemos usar su apariencia para distinguirlos.
Tenemos que usar ADN, como una huella dactilar,
para decir quién es quién.
Y les enseñaré cómo hacerlo ahora mismo.
Inventé algunos datos y les mostraré algunos datos que no son reales.
Esto es para ilustrar cómo se vería
si un grupo de especies no estuviera relacionado entre sí en absoluto.
Y se puede ver cada especie
hay una lista de combinaciones de A, G, C y T,
que son las cuatro subunidades del ADN,
algo aleatoriamente desordenado, y nada se parece a nada más,
y estas especies no tienen ninguna relación entre sí.
Pero así es como se ve el ADN real,
de un gen que comparten estas especies.
Todo se alinea casi a la perfección.
Las posibilidades de obtener tantas de esas columnas verticales
donde cada especie tiene una C o cada especie tiene una T,
por azar, son infinitesimales.
Sabemos que todas esas especies tenían que haber tenido un ancestro común.
Todos son parientes el uno del otro.
Así que ahora les diré quiénes son.
Los dos arriba somos nosotros y los chimpancés,
que ya sabían que estaban relacionados, porque, quiero decir, obviamente.
(Risas)
Pero también estamos relacionados con cosas que no se nos parecen,
como pinos y la giardiosis, que es esa enfermedad gastrointestinal
se puede tener si no se filtra el agua en una excursión.
También estamos relacionados con bacterias E. coli y Clostridium difficile,
patógenos horribles y oportunistas que matan a muchas personas.
Pero también hay buenos microbios, como el Dehalococcoides ethenogenes,
que limpia nuestros desechos industriales.
Y, si tomo estas secuencias de ADN,
y luego uso las similitudes y diferencias entre ellos,
para hacer un árbol genealógico de todos nosotros
y para que se vea quién está estrechamente relacionado,
es así como aparece.
Para que pueda ver claramente, a simple vista,
que cosas como nosotros, la Giardia lamblia, los conejos y los pinos
son todos, como, hermanos,
y las bacterias son como nuestros primos antiguos.
Pero somos parientes de todos los seres vivos en la Tierra.
Y en mi trabajo a diario,
produzco evidencia científica contra la soledad existencial.
Y cuando obtuvimos estas primeras secuencias de ADN,
desde el primer crucero de muestras prístinas del subsuelo profundo,
queríamos saber dónde estaban.
Y lo primero que descubrimos es que no eran extraterrestres,
porque podríamos hacer que su ADN se alineara con todo lo demás en la Tierra.
Pero ahora vean a dónde van en nuestro árbol de la vida.
Lo primero que notarán es que hay muchos de ellos.
No era solo una pequeña especie
que logró vivir en este horrible lugar.
Es un montón de cosas.
Y lo segundo que notarán,
con suerte, es que no se parecen a nada que hayamos visto antes.
Son tan diferentes el uno del otro
como son de todo lo que conocíamos antes
como somos nosotros de los pinos.
John Parkes estaba completamente en lo correcto.
Él, y nosotros, habíamos descubierto un completamente nuevo y muy diverso
ecosistema microbiano en la Tierra
que nadie sabía que existía antes de los años ochenta.
Estábamos en una buena racha.
El siguiente paso fue cultivar esas especies exóticas en una placa de Petri
para hacer experimentos reales con ellas
como se supone que deben hacer los microbiólogos.
Pero con independencia de lo que les dimos,
ellos se negaron a crecer
Incluso ahora, 15 años y muchas expediciones más tarde,
ningún humano ha logrado hacer crecer uno de estos microbios exóticos
del subsuelo profundo en una placa de Petri.
Y no es por falta de intentos.
Eso puede sonar decepcionante,
pero en realidad lo encuentro estimulante,
porque significa que hay muchas incógnitas incitantes en las que trabajar.
Mis colegas y yo tuvimos lo que pensamos que era una gran idea.
Íbamos a leer sus genes como un libro de recetas,
averiguar qué era lo que querían comer y ponerlo en sus placas de Petri,
y luego ellos crecerían y serían felices.
Pero cuando miramos sus genes,
resulta que lo que querían comer era la comida que ya les estábamos dando.
Y eso fue un total fracaso.
Había algo más que querían en sus placas de Petri
que simplemente no les dábamos.
Así que combinando medidas de muchos lugares diferentes
alrededor del mundo,
mis colegas en la Universidad del Sur de California,
Doug LaRowe y Jan Amend,
lograron calcular que cada una de esas células microbianas de aguas profundas
requiere solo de un zeptowatt de potencia,
y antes de que abran sus teléfonos, un zeptowatt es de 10 a la menos 21,
porque sé que a mí me gustaría mirar eso.
Los humanos, por otro lado,
requieren alrededor de 100 vatios de potencia.
Y 100 vatios es básicamente si uno agarra una piña y
la deja a caer de la altura de la cintura hasta el suelo 88 1632 veces por día.
Si lo hiciéramos y luego lo conectáramos a una turbina,
eso crearía suficiente energía para hacernos pasar un día.
Un zeptowatt, en términos similares,
es si se toma solo un grano de sal
y luego uno se imagina una pequeña, pequeña pelota,
eso es una milésima de la masa de ese grano de sal,
y luego lo dejas caer un nanómetro,
que es cien veces más pequeño que la longitud de onda de la luz visible,
una vez al día.
Eso es todo lo que se necesita para hacer que estos microbios vivan.
Eso es menos energía de lo que pensamos sería capaz de soportar la vida,
pero de alguna manera, increíblemente, bellamente,
es suficiente.
Si estos microbios profundos subsuperficiales
tienen una relación muy diferente con la energía de lo que creíamos,
se deduce que tendrán que tener
una relación diferente con el tiempo también.
Porque cuando se vive en tan pequeños gradientes de energía,
el crecimiento rápido es imposible.
Si estas cosas quisieran colonizar nuestras gargantas y enfermarnos,
serian echados por estreptococos de veloz crecimiento
antes de que pudieran iniciar su división celular.
Y por eso nunca los encontramos en nuestras gargantas.
Tal vez el hecho de que el subsuelo profundo es tan aburrido
es realmente un activo para estos microbios.
Nunca son arrastrados por una tormenta.
Nunca dejan de crecer por las malas hierbas.
Todo lo que tienen que hacer es existir.
Tal vez esa cosa que nos faltaba en nuestras placas de Petri
no era comida en absoluto.
Quizás no fue un químico.
Tal vez lo que realmente quieren,
el nutriente que quieren, es tiempo.
Pero el tiempo es lo único que nunca podré darles.
Incluso si tengo un cultivo celular que paso a mis estudiantes de doctorado,
quien se lo pasa a sus estudiantes de doctorado, y así sucesivamente,
Tendríamos que hacer eso durante miles de años
para imitar las condiciones exactas del subsuelo profundo,
todo sin cultivar ningún contaminante.
Simplemente no es posible.
Pero de alguna manera ya los hemos cultivado en nuestras placas de Petri.
Tal vez vieron toda la comida que les ofrecimos y dijeron:
"Gracias, voy a acelerar tanto
que voy a hacer una nueva célula el próximo siglo.
Uy.
(Risas)
Y, ¿por qué el resto de la biología se mueve tan rápido?
¿Por qué una célula muere después de un día?
y un humano muere después de solo cien años?
Estos parecen límites realmente arbitrariamente cortos
cuando se piensa en la cantidad total de tiempo en el universo.
Pero estos no son límites arbitrarios.
Están dictados por una cosa simple,
y esa cosa es el sol
Una vez que la vida descubrió cómo aprovechar la energía del sol
a través de la fotosíntesis,
todos tuvimos que acelerar y lograr ciclos de día y de noche.
De esa manera, el Sol nos dio a ambos una razón para ser rápidos
y el combustible para hacerlo.
Se puede ver la mayor parte de la vida en la Tierra como un sistema circulatorio,
y el sol es nuestro corazón latente
Pero el subsuelo profundo es como un sistema circulatorio
completamente desconectado del Sol
pero impulsado por ritmos geológicos largos y lentos.
Actualmente no existe un límite teórico sobre la vida útil de una sola célula.
Mientras haya al menos un pequeño gradiente de energía para explotar,
teóricamente, una sola célula podría vivir
durante cientos de miles de años o más,
simplemente reemplazando partes rotas con el tiempo.
Pedirle a un microbio que vive así que crezca en nuestras placas de Petri
es pedirles que se adapten a muestra forma de vida frenética,
centrada en el Sol, pero quizá ellos tengan cosas mejores que hacer,
(Risas)
Imagínense si pudiéramos descubrir cómo lograron hacer esto.
¿Y si involucra algunos compuestos interesantes y ultraestables?
que podríamos usar para aumentar la vida útil
en aplicaciones biomédicas o industriales?
O tal vez si descubrimos el mecanismo que usan
para crecer tan extraordinariamente lentos,
podríamos imitarlo en las células cancerosas
y frenar la división celular incontrolada.
No lo sé.
Es decir, honestamente, eso es toda especulación,
pero lo único que sé con certeza
es que hay cien billones de billones
de células microbianas vivientes
subyacentes a todos los océanos del mundo.
Eso es 200 veces más que la biomasa total de humanos en este planeta.
Y esos microbios tienen una relación fundamentalmente diferente
con el tiempo y la energía que nosotros.
Lo que parece un día para ellos
podría ser mil años para nosotros.
No les importa el Sol,
y no les importa crecer rápido,
y probablemente no les importa un comino mi placa de Petri...
(Risas)
pero si podemos continuar encontrando maneras creativas de estudiarlos,
tal vez finalmente descubramos cómo es la vida, toda la vida en la Tierra.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)